I'm going to talk a little bit about a relatively esoteric topic, and I will give those of you
who are not large cell specialists an overview of why we did this study.
If you go slow, Wyndham, they're just filtering in now.
Okay, so actually, this study was done to determine what the genetic underpinnings are for Bruton tyrosine kinase.
So I'm going to turn back about 25 years and go over a little bit of history.
Why do we care?
And most of you know that work that Ash Lazaday and Lou Stout did back in 2012.
I identified two major types that are based on their origin of differentiation, ABC type and the germinal center type.
And what I show on the right there is a list of NF-kappa B target genes.
And you can see very clearly that all the red for these target genes is present within the ABC type.
Why do we care?
Well, the reason we care is that we've now further defined multiple genetic types.
And as you can see here, the ABC type is made up of a number of different genetic subtypes, as is the germinal center type.
And there are other subtypes, such as BN2, that actually is present within ABC or the GCB subtype,
or within the BN2.
And so what we want to do here is we want to be unclassified.
And unclassified is simply that we could not, from a statistical point of view and from a genetic point of view,
put it into a specific type.
And so what is driving NF-kappa B?
Well, what's driving NF-kappa B is chronic B-cell receptor signaling.
And this is showing the cascade all the way down to NF-kappa B.
And you can see here, the B-cell receptor signaling is showing the cascade all the way down to NF-kappa B.
And you can see there are multiple activating mutations along the way.
One of the very first studies ever done to see whether or not we could perturb this pathway was done by us.
And we were focusing on BTK.
And we performed a phase 1-2 study of using ibrutinib, the first gen BTK inhibitor.
And this is actually the waterfall plot that came from that study in relapsed refractory large cell.
And you can see in red that almost all of the activity was within ABC.
And based on that study, J&J went on to do a randomized study of ARCA plus or minus ibrutinib
and they were able to do a randomized study of ARCA plus or minus ibrutinib within ABC.
And based on that study, J&J went on to do a randomized study of ARCA plus or minus ibrutinib within ABC.
And you can see here that on the left for people that were under 60,
there was a significant advantage to adding ibrutinib.
The overall results when you combine people less than 60 and over 60,
this was the Phoenix trial, showed no benefit.
However, it was because we found for the first time that ibrutinib caused,
however, it was because we found for the first time that ibrutinib caused,
however, it was because we found for the first time that ibrutinib caused, problems with counts,
problems with counts,
problems with counts, problems with the ability to give full dose
problems with the ability to give full dose
problems with the ability to give full dose chop.
chop.
chop. And so we did this analysis.
And so we did this analysis.
And so we did this analysis. And you can also see down at the bottom
And you can also see down at the bottom
And you can also see down at the bottom on the left that the MCD type,
on the left that the MCD type,
on the left that the MCD type, which is the most classic type of ABC,
which is the most classic type of ABC,
which is the most classic type of ABC, had actually 100% PFS.
had actually 100% PFS.
had actually 100% PFS. And you can see in the next panel up
And you can see in the next panel up
And you can see in the next panel up that it was significant within the ABC
that it was significant within the ABC
that it was significant within the ABC type 2.
type 2.
type 2. So we decided, and this study we started
So we decided, and this study we started
So we decided, and this study we started numbers of years ago,
numbers of years ago,
numbers of years ago, to ask the question as to what is the
to ask the question as to what is the
to ask the question as to what is the genetic underpinning of
genetic underpinning of
genetic underpinning of activity to a BTK.
activity to a BTK.
activity to a BTK. And so these were untreated patients.
And so these were untreated patients.
And so these were untreated patients. They received two weeks of,
They received two weeks of,
They received two weeks of, actually in this case, we're using
actually in this case, we're using
actually in this case, we're using acalabrutinib, and if they had
acalabrutinib, and if they had
acalabrutinib, and if they had less than a 25% reduction,
less than a 25% reduction,
less than a 25% reduction, they received chemotherapy by itself.
they received chemotherapy by itself.
they received chemotherapy by itself. If they had a greater than 25%,
If they had a greater than 25%,
If they had a greater than 25%, they received ibrutinib+.
they received ibrutinib+.
they received ibrutinib+. We had about 49 patients in each
We had about 49 patients in each
We had about 49 patients in each group, as it turned out.
group, as it turned out.
group, as it turned out. The patients on this study, again,
The patients on this study, again,
The patients on this study, again, we have 99 patients on this study,
we have 99 patients on this study,
we have 99 patients on this study, median age 60, and
median age 60, and
median age 60, and median time to diagnosis was 25 days.
median time to diagnosis was 25 days.
median time to diagnosis was 25 days. IPI greater than or equal to 3 was 47%.
IPI greater than or equal to 3 was 47%.
IPI greater than or equal to 3 was 47%. So this is actually showing you what
So this is actually showing you what
So this is actually showing you what this window study found.
this window study found.
this window study found. And really, the whole point of the
And really, the whole point of the
And really, the whole point of the study was to do a window study.
study was to do a window study.
study was to do a window study. And you can see, unexpectedly,
And you can see, unexpectedly,
And you can see, unexpectedly, that the response rate within
that the response rate within
that the response rate within germinal center, 43% of the
germinal center, 43% of the
germinal center, 43% of the tumors shrank with it.
tumors shrank with it.
tumors shrank with it. Within the ABC type, it was 53%.
Within the ABC type, it was 53%.
Within the ABC type, it was 53%. Within the unclassified, it was 83%.
Within the unclassified, it was 83%. And so we actually looked at what the
And so we actually looked at what the
And so we actually looked at what the activity was within the various
activity was within the various
activity was within the various genetic types. I just show this to
genetic types. I just show this to
genetic types. I just show this to show that activity was seen in
show that activity was seen in
show that activity was seen in mostly the ABC types. And you can
mostly the ABC types. And you can
mostly the ABC types. And you can see, although we used 25% as the
see, although we used 25% as the
see, although we used 25% as the cutoff, there were plenty of patients
cutoff, there were plenty of patients
cutoff, there were plenty of patients that had more than 25%.
that had more than 25%.
that had more than 25%. And this is actually showing you what
And this is actually showing you what
And this is actually showing you what the overall activity was. MCD or
the overall activity was. MCD or
the overall activity was. MCD or N1, we consider to be the most
N1, we consider to be the most
N1, we consider to be the most addicted patients, most addicted
addicted patients, most addicted
addicted patients, most addicted types to B-cell receptor
types to B-cell receptor
types to B-cell receptor signaling, and the response rate
signaling, and the response rate
signaling, and the response rate was 100%, 6 out of 6.
was 100%, 6 out of 6.
was 100%, 6 out of 6. EZB, which is a classic germinal
EZB, which is a classic germinal
EZB, which is a classic germinal center type, it was still active at
center type, it was still active at
center type, it was still active at 58%, A3, which is the P53 type of
58%, A3, which is the P53 type of
58%, A3, which is the P53 type of 50%, etc. And then when we go to
50%, etc. And then when we go to
50%, etc. And then when we go to BN2, it was 33% EZB-MIC, which is
BN2, it was 33% EZB-MIC, which is
BN2, it was 33% EZB-MIC, which is also known as the
also known as the
also known as the dark zone type was also
dark zone type was also
dark zone type was also about a third.
about a third.
about a third. This is less... I really can't say much
This is less... I really can't say much
This is less... I really can't say much about
about
about the actual clinical outcome, because
the actual clinical outcome, because
the actual clinical outcome, because this was not meant to address a
this was not meant to address a
this was not meant to address a chemotherapy
chemotherapy
chemotherapy calibrutinib outcome, but this is just
calibrutinib outcome, but this is just
calibrutinib outcome, but this is just showing you the PFS outcome, which was
showing you the PFS outcome, which was
showing you the PFS outcome, which was about 78-79%
about 78-79%
about 78-79% with a median follow-up of 39 months.
with a median follow-up of 39 months.
with a median follow-up of 39 months. So a very mature group.
So a very mature group.
So a very mature group. And if we look at people again,
And if we look at people again,
And if we look at people again, you have to interpret this with some
you have to interpret this with some
you have to interpret this with some cautious the calibrutin responders
cautious the calibrutin responders
cautious the calibrutin responders versus non, the outcomes were the same.
versus non, the outcomes were the same.
versus non, the outcomes were the same. And if we look at the non-responders by
And if we look at the non-responders by
And if we look at the non-responders by ABC unclassified or
ABC unclassified or
ABC unclassified or germinal center types, the outcomes
germinal center types, the outcomes
germinal center types, the outcomes were similar. However, if we looked
were similar. However, if we looked
were similar. However, if we looked at the responders by GCB unclassified
at the responders by GCB unclassified
at the responders by GCB unclassified ABC, the outcome was poor within the
ABC, the outcome was poor within the
ABC, the outcome was poor within the ABC type.
ABC type.
ABC type. Even though we were using a
Even though we were using a
Even though we were using a BTK windows in those cases, they
BTK windows in those cases, they
BTK windows in those cases, they still nonetheless did somewhat worse.
still nonetheless did somewhat worse.
still nonetheless did somewhat worse. And so with that, I'm one minute and 31
And so with that, I'm one minute and 31
And so with that, I'm one minute and 31 seconds late.
seconds late.
seconds late. So let me just say that
So let me just say that
So let me just say that I originally did the study with Mark
I originally did the study with Mark
I originally did the study with Mark Rochefsky, who unfortunately left us
Rochefsky, who unfortunately left us
Rochefsky, who unfortunately left us to go to
to go to
to go to MSK.
MSK.
MSK. And so Chris Maloney, one of my other
And so Chris Maloney, one of my other
And so Chris Maloney, one of my other faculty, is now PI on this. And of
faculty, is now PI on this. And of
faculty, is now PI on this. And of course
course
course Lou's lab did all the genetics and
I worked with all these folks.
Thank you.